yeah welcome to this video playing a 15
min the game against defenestration Jeff
have no idea what this means alright so
i played this funny line of the french
that international master and well-known
with irritation theoretician john watson
recently produced a video series upon
the knight c6 french or as he courted
the hecht refresh llegar variation named
after German players some ants you're
hitched and Hamish later okay so
interesting he took on f6 plate f5 so is
giving me the two bishops I always like
that admittedly this is nothing special
I mean for black but it it doesn't feel
too threatening to me how should I play
night before and play see 5 or
what is my continuation here I could
also play a 6 it's not it's not bad
immediately aiming at the pawn I like
both actually night before intending
maybe to even grab the second bishop and
prepare c5 96's a bit weird looking but
it's not a bad move yeah the blocking of
the sea porn but it's it's not a big
deal alright so we cancelled
I don't really need to Castle quickly
yeah the question is should i take even
or should I play 96 96 is not bad I even
prefer that to be honest because he
cannot play 90 to see four wins the
bishop he cannot really support the
center now I think he needs to take and
exchanging d4c pong should be a quite
comfortable here all right okay so after
taking he wants to he wants to play 92
yeah okay still I like to do an exchange
here Queen B 6 yeah why not yeah I hoped
to provoke that
so back to be eight
but to be aging so that I can go to be 6
later
yeah should be for two to attack the
rook
yeah not sure if Fisher before really
really improved my position okay but I
want to play Quincy 796 Bishop d7
something like that and trying to play
on the C file
yeah I want to prevent night h5 i still
this pc eight bishop how to how to get
this sorted
yeah I need to move the Queen and then
Knight b6 Bishop d7 something like that
attitude and tie those pieces here
the night on b6 is not badly placed it
attacks a form and why it always needs
to worry about that
I wonder if I can't get along here
Bishop d7 had long castle so maybe not
so bad
I play fairly quickly unusual but
probably are useful yeah I had all the
time I have the possibility to play
Bishop c3 but I don't want to do that
really it keeps the d4 pawn but I don't
want to put it on c3 because I probably
need to play Bishop e7 at some point to
cover the dark squares or fh to g7
something like that to make sure that
there's nothing bad happening on those
sir those squares this is why I don't
play Bishop c3 maybe it's a good move
very often the computer just ignores
those kind of things and says okay
there's nothing happening i played this
anyway and maybe after Bishop c3 here
needs to play really sick looking move
like bouquet to to cover a form but I
really don't want to worry about that I
want this as a possible defense of peas
on his heaven
okay he's trying to play the C porn but
no if I was hanging and I'm going to
take it yeah i think that i cannot i
cannot i cannot not take it I need to
take it I have put my night there for a
reason and on c4 which is the thing I
could have played 93 okay he took on
deform yeah so Knight c3 it looks it
looks dangerous I'm attacking e5 as well
so now just take if I of him also d for
us hanging everything's hanging here if
you know it's probably this is probably
all right I don't really believe that
rookie one or something as I can just
take the form there's no no big attack
Quinn f6
this Knight c3 Bishop before they cover
each other nicely and it's not really
clear what white is so threatening
how many points is that by the way seven
against I've got two extra pounds okay
yeah and I think I'll threatening e5
resigns well this was early oh ok I
probably it is e 5 is really helpful to
meet ya the compass of minus five
already- for something yeah it's it's
two points and I have to set down some
there's not really a big big attack or
something brewing also bishop d6s Sam it
should be six attacking here it's quite
good this night is completely I'm
dominating the position I don't really
believe that that let's take a couple of
months back I'm not an expert on this
opening I only watched a bit of this
what's serious I think he had Bishop b5
here as a possible move which was yeah
somewhere between equal and slightly
better for white I don't really think
that II five is too great i mean this
kind of structure I know it is closed
then the Knights are supposed to be good
there but you really lack the dark
squared Bishop former White lots of the
text sound dark squares and it's
difficult also to maintain the center
against f6 and the latency five in fact
after this I think that black is quite
comfortable yeah here it can also take I
can just take d three not bad at all of
course okay I like to attack the sender
yeah yes it's questionable if I need to
play a five immediately Bishop d7 root
CA this may be better yeah maybe
something like this and then a six-night
bag we should be five or so could be an
idea yeah this is not bad good probably
not the best this is really annoying he
probably needs to do something like that
and try to avoid they form a four-wheel
he weakens the queenside yeah it's a
typical French position for some
fighting chances for both sides black
now he probably plays the 90 and 55 to
bishops yep interesting fight the way it
went that was some it was really a
difficult position for wide he needs to
I think try to get it back here maybe
Queen to f4 and something like that no
alright thanks for watching